you
the things that I remember most vividly
were when I I gave a talk about the work
okay and I remember being relaxed even
though this was being televised and not
feeling you know that I been feeling
very quite quite comfortable to giving
up and giving an hour-long talk in that
was being televised thousands of people
at least then when they had the the
ceremony and I was supposed to grow up
and receive the prize from a king before
that happened I this may be an old
familiar story but before that happened
I became increasingly nervous in fact in
spite of the fact that I had very little
to actually do and almost nothing to say
except thank you I you know I recall
being extremely nervous in that regard
and managed to get through it they I
don't know whether I don't know the
origin such nervousness whether it was I
was going to drop it or or I would not
would would fall down on the way or
whatever